I dated him in the last seven years
because I think that he's so funny that
when I have to sit through conversing
with very unfunny people it I kind of
just like - now I'm not even drinking
he's without one of the funniest people
I've ever met so fun and I have to say
the same thing has started to apply oh
yeah like oh [ __ ] you know some porn
people just you know just throw the dad
jokes and you're like oh yeah I like to
sit there and pretend to enjoy funny my
question today is what are you gonna do
stand-up yeah officially if I invite me
man well you're here so honestly though
yeah whoo you did and we're not gonna
cut this out I don't care if what you
say okay would you ever try it of course
I would are you writing stuff now I'm
not no honestly I want you to start just
writing bits down now the ideas so
because it I feel like when it happens
it's gonna be like two weeks like it's
gonna be like hey and Jay in two weeks
you're gonna do it so you need to stop
prepping I could write some [ __ ] in two
weeks would it be under the gun you know
no pressure baby diamond because he did
it how'd it go how we okay how many
seats did you wear how many people were
in the audience 700 I think
700 and will you go for what was your
like what was your POV he did a futon
joke started strong
Oh Jane Hey Ya ye without jokes when he
was on stage Gilbert and I ran into the
audience sat down yeah and what did I
keep saying I don't like him yeah you he
wanted the lights to be pulled
immediately I thought he was bombing so
bad I'm sorry I'm Jesus to come when you
do think that's a rite of passage you
have to bomb yeah like that you got it
out of the way all the next time here's
the thing dude George it's the fact that
how many times have you done that takes
[ __ ] balls dude yeah hundred you've
done hundreds of times since then right
yeah and to eat it that bad people and
so crushing oh so crushing to keep doing
it our movie it's a [ __ ] Power Move
brother yeah I'm so proud of you yeah
futon forever man crushed GJ would take
the probably the same approaches of me
it's kind of black out with our prepared
jokes and improvise that's what I would
do that yeah I'd probably just like riff
you know like I think the interaction
would be fun I did it 10 times yeah
terrible so you know he makes everyone
he likes do stand-up tickets Michael
Rosenbaum who had never done it before I
invited him at the Irvine improv yeah
and he just went up and did it loved it
Will Sasso never done yeah Will Sasso
and let me tell you something when they
do it in front of a packed room
especially if it's not going well
and they can keep it together right
there's such a I'm so [ __ ] proud for
- dude
it really is you know mean that these
people are just ballsy and taking risks
and and and just just doing it you know
you gotta have a heart you gotta have a
magnum p.i like you should do a show in
Hawaii and have them open up right
you've done we should do that yeah show
a weekend you host you feature
oh you hobby boy would do it - jo koy
wants me to open for him for 30,000 it
could go in front of 30,000 people yeah
yeah I think I would imagine that like
if you have more people maybe that would
be some matter G you would be so [ __ ]
scared back there you wouldn't be no
here's the challenge he wants me to be
so I won't be so I won't press you this
for three weeks on the podcast he
promoted to the whole entire audience to
come to the show to watch me do stand-up
for the first time so I can bomb trust
me guys she's gonna bum you guys that's
what I did I thought you know what I was
so nervous about this one which this is
podcast because hotel room because we
never we always do it in my house never
done it like this and I really we should
just do this all the time on the road
it's fun these two guys were amazing
it was Korean it's